well magnus funk is zoom cio advisor and
he joins me now magnus welcome to you um
how does this improve on the existing
service
well uh hello ian and thank you so much
for having me on the show um
zoom one is a platform evolution it
brings together meetings chat whiteboard
phone and more to make connections that
matter
and of course simplicity is security at
the core of everything that zoom does
and as the zoom platform has evolved
from a meetings app to a comprehensive
communications platform it was clear
that introducing new packaging like zoom
one was the next step in the company's
evolution
and is this being targeted more at
individual users or at business
customers
this is across our platform um very much
our focus has always been on business to
business um
use
we saw a huge number of consumers use
the platform during the pandemic but our
core business is um servicing the
business user and so the zoom one pla
the zoom one announcement is really
aimed at helping them do business with
us
and what's the charging model for the
new platform
well it's a very um
sensible set of um plans providing zooms
customers with different levels of
meeting capabilities cloud storage zoom
phone zoom whiteboard and of course our
translations where we're translating
english to 10 languages and 10 languages
to english and having captions in those
languages as well and the enterprise
plans benefit from additional solutions
such as our fabulous zoom rooms and if
you've never been in the zoom room it's
a
wonderful experience and of course
zoom's webinars
and how rapidly do you expect to roll
this out across the world
well this um zoom one is available now
and so we can be talking to business
customers today about um the zoom one
approach
and how much does it cost to develop
well we invest hugely in our platform
we're one of the most innovative
software companies you've seen that with
our the evolution from yeah a software
company was only set up 10 years built
to do video right and now we have a
platform with video frictionless video
first communications right at the core
of it so we're not really focused on
building zoom one as a separate thing it
is actually the evolution of our whole
platform uh which we invest in hugely
every year
and
what are you seeing in terms of
usage right now around the world prior
to this new launch i mean obviously
there's been a lot of commentary on wall
street about uh numbers tailing off
since the return to work what's what are
you seeing in reality
well we've seen um
employers embrace hybrid work styles
they they've realized that their
employees want flexibility their
customers want flexibility and also
they've worked out that by inventing new
services that
can
be delivered by employees working
differently to customers who are also at
home they actually have a chance to
innovate and deliver more of what their
customers want so we're seeing
that the the what we provide is more
embedded into businesses than ever
before and
the zoom one announcement really is a
reflection of that they businesses want
our whole platform they want a simple
way of doing business with us and um so
we're responding to that market demand
what have you seen in the uk this week i
mean the city has been like a morgue all
week here with the rail strikes on i i
assume everyone is uh using zoom a lot
more this week
well
we feel really sorry for everyone
impacted by um the industrial action and
and we hope there's a swift result in
the um negotiations
but while there isn't people have
switched to the way they know is
possible to work and this
zoom has already been a flexible part of
their work life and their life as a
customer so they know how to do this and
and we're really delighted to be there
at their time of need
all right magnus good to talk to you
this morning thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot for having me